hi this video is about cells of the
immune system in my earlier video I have
compared the immune system of our body
to the defense system of our country so
if you haven't watched this video please
watch this video for better convenience
now question is from where does that
immune cells of our body arise it turns
out that all the immune cells most of
them are produced from the bone marrow
and bone marrow is found in big bones
like one depicted here so inside the
bone there would be bone marrow and in
the bone marrow there are two niche one
is vascular niche mohnish industrial
niche and mostly industrial niche
comprises of the hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cell now hematopoietic
will put in stem cell give rise to
myeloid progenitor or lymphoid
progenitor from the myeloid progenitor
all the part of the innate immune system
arises such as macrophages such as
neutrophils basophils Marcel etc etc now
from the lymphoid progenitor or the
adaptive part of the immune system
appears for example T lymphocyte B
lymphocyte and natural killer cells now
first we would look at the components of
the innate part of the immune system and
then we would move to look at the
adaptive part so one of the important
player of the innate immune system is
the macrophage macrophages are like
patrolling police but first let's look
at where does macrophages come from
macrophages come from hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cell and thereby in
actually differentiate into Milo and
progenitor and ultimately give rise to
monocytes monocytes enter the
bloodstream circulate in the bloodstream
and once they enter the tissue space
they become macrophages the macrophages
are munna and monocytes are the same but
Mat monocytes are circulating in the
blood vessels whereas macrophages are
resident in the
and they're patrolling around the border
of the scheme or any other epithelial
lining like that so that's why I want to
describe macrophages as patrolling
police officer
so whenever a pathogen is entering our
body like here our nail is bringing our
skin and with the rusty nail
there are pathogens entering our body so
since the macrophages are always
patrolling our bound scheme it can
recognize the pathogen macrophage can
recognize the pathogen and it can kill
the pathogens
the one of the way it uses to kill the
pathogen is by using reactive oxygen
species other way engulf the pathogen
and kill it by lysozymes
also a second type of cell which is a
part of both kind of adaptive an innate
immune system it's sort of work like a
bridging cell is known as dendritic cell
now dendritic cells can bear name from
ten writeline projections so they are
not neurons they don't have dendrites
but they have projections which are very
similar to dendrites so that's why they
are known as dendritic cell dendritic
cells are also antigen presenting cells
they're also compared like a patrolling
police officer like macrophages they
also hover around near the boundaries of
the skin in our respiratory epithelial
etcetera etcetera now whenever a
pathogen enters dendritic cell can
engulf the pathogen and it can first
take some measure to destroy the
pathogen and also it can alarm the
adaptive part of the immune system the
reserve part of the immune system to
take further actions now I would
introduce you to such toxic t-cells not
t-cells are of two types
so they are like reserved armies and
specialized armies for example cytotoxic
T cells are specialized killer or forces
so they would recognize which cell is
infected so generally what happens they
they give
to immunity against virus infected cell
a virus infected cell would display some
of the viral proteins on its surface by
class one image now cytotoxic cd8 t-cell
can recognize that viral particle on the
class one MHC and thereby it can secrete
trans Iams and perforins which are which
which can ultimately give rise to
activation of caspase 3 and thereby
apoptosis of the target cell thereby it
kills its target cell or affected cell
in the system now other cell is known as
cd8 positive helper T cell now helper T
cell are reserved page of army so they
are ready to come back but they don't
generally come back directly so what
does they do they work like helpers so
they help other cells for example
b-cells to get activated so T helper
cells help B cell to get activated and
take the further action now P cells are
another division of army for example
think that if cd8 positive T cells are
land forces and imagine B cells as Navy
so b-cells has developed from the bone
marrow from the bone marrow immature B
cell goes to the lymph node lymph node
are like base camp for P cells also T
cells now in lymph node they recite they
are ready to combat and in the lymph
node they also interact with other
patrolling police officers that means
the macrophages and the dendrites to
understand what kind of pathogen has
even invaded our body so there are
specific zones for b-cell in the lymph
node that is sewn like lymphoid follicle
where P cells reside also the B cell
once encountered a pathogen
the rapidly proliferate and from the
charm centered Jeremy now seemed a
center in the lymph node
now once B cell is activated it
undergoes affinity maturation and
antibody class switching to produce one
type of antibody in large amount and the
B cell gain differentiated into a
antibody secreting plasma cell now
plasma cell is the main activated killer
part of the B cell also I would talk
about natural killer cell natural killer
cell is also of lymphoid origin and
natural killer cells are SpecOps they
are like little killers of the immune
system so they don't differentiate
between anything so anything in their
way they would kill so what happens in
this situation let's say our cell is
infected by a virus now definitely our
immune system has a antiviral mechanism
of action which is by cd8 positive T
cell sometimes the virus is so cunning
that we don't allow the cell to display
viral peptide onto a class 1 MHC now
once the cell cannot display the viral
peptides on class 1 MHC C really
positive T cell would think everything
is under control and everything is okay
but the NK cells are different NK cells
go to cell to cell and scan for class 1
MHC anywhere it would see the class 1
MHC molecules are not there or peptides
displays on the class 1 molecules are
not there it would think there is
something wrong and it would destroy the
cell by secreting 414 and granzymes so
NK cells are pretty clever and cunning
other cells which are of myeloid lineage
is like your snowfield marcelles base a
few neutral field all these things are
also important component of the
immune system because all of these are
important for allergic responses so they
are mainly the mediators of inflammatory
responses definitely they help to
modulate the adaptive immune response
and also they're involved in allergic
responses so what happens
Marcelle and basal field has antibody
receptors on their surface known as FC
receptor now FC receptor can bind to the
FC portion of the antibodies now upon
really upon repeated exposure of an
allergen here in a green so you can see
the antibodies cross-linked at and it
would make the mast cells and basophils
etc 2d granulate so it would deregulate
huge amount of histamine or other
inflammatory mediators including
prostaglandin leukotriene etc and etc
and that would create a lot of changes
in the body including vasodilation
bronchial constriction smooth muscle
contraction etc etc so these cells are
mostly important for allergic responses
now we have quite a lot of looked at
what are the cell types present in the
immune system how they are compared to a
division of armies in a country now we
should think about that all the armies
for example where forces land forces and
navy are well connected by specific
communication system so how does our
immune system communicate with each
other it turns out that immune system
has different strategies to communicate
with each other either they migrate from
one place to another place to direct
contact with another cell for example a
macrophage who wants encounter a
pathogen at the at the periphery of the
body that means hundun in the skin it
would migrate towards the lymph node
that means the base camp of the T cell
or B cell and it would interact with
them it would activate them to become do
to combat the situation now
so the one kind of direct one kind of
direct mode of activation or mode of
communication is receptor based
interaction receptor based interaction
give rise to specific signaling which
would convey a message message of the
pathogen innovation or which would tell
for this this immune component cell to
get activated other ways of
communication is kind of wellness
communication or radio based
communication used by the armies which
are cycles so macrophages or many other
cells of the immune system secrete
cytokines so cytokines are chemical
messengers cytokines would bind to the
cytokine receptor on the target cell and
create a lot of signaling molecule in
pathways which would ultimately give
rise to several downstream effects for
example cytokine release inflammatory
cytokines namely interleukin 1 and
interleukin 6 released by the macrophage
would attract even more macrophages
towards the sort of site of invasion as
if the macrophage is asking for backup
for from its unit to come to the place
and combat more pathogen so this is how
this is a brief idea about how the
immune system communicate with each
other from all these parts and all these
cells I have separate detailed videos so
you can watch those and get a detailed
idea about how each of these components
or each of these definitions of the
immune system work so that kind of
concludes my video on this topic if you
like my video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you